retrouver manger
svuté avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires bonjour c'est beau hein la
Cité de Carcassonne la perle de l'ude
vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui manger
svoté est en Occitanie dans l'eaue le
numéro 11 et on va rencontrer ensemble
Sébastien là le sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicain qui nous
attend au château de per Pertus au site
Qatar c'est aussi ça
[Musique]
l'ude
bonjour monsieur le sénateur bonjour
bienvenue à ptus ah bah écoutez merci de
m'y accueillir sous cette citadelle
incroyable château de perpertus alors
c'est un haut lieu du département et du
catarisme un haut lieu historique de de
la puissance de la couronne française
sous le château là dans la vallée il y a
un très au village comment
s'appelle-t-il duyac soupay repertus
duyac c'est chez vous c'est chez moi
c'est là que vous êtes né c'est c'est là
où j'ai été conçu c'est là où mon père
est né mes grands-parents sont nés c'est
le berceau familial où j'habite toujours
quel est votre métier à l'origine mon
premier poste était directeur d'office
de tourisme et puis très rapidement j'ai
été propulsé maire de mon petit village
de dutus à l'âge de 23 ans ça pas été
simple au départ parce c'était pas prévu
moi j'ai jamais fait de politique je
suis pas né dans un parti je j'ai pas
milit je faisais pas un projet de vie et
de carrière du tout et je me suis
retrouvé maire d'un petit village al
vous allez me dire un petit village 150
habitants bon il rien d'extraordinaire
si ce n'est que ce petit village est
propriétaire de l'un des plus
fantastiques monuments du département de
l' de Château de payt et grâce à ce
château j'ai créé du réseau et puis on
initie des choses on réalise des projets
et on se prend un jeu c'est magnifique
quand on fait un mer est un feur d'abord
et avant tout c'est probablement le seul
élu de la République qui quand il a une
idée pour arriver au bout et la réaliser
vous vous sentez un peu comme le
capitaine de de l'équipe des mairres de
votre territoire c'est c'est ça être
sénateur pour vous oui c'est ça vous
savez 20 ans j'ai été lumire pendant 20
ans je l'ai vécu mais à 200 % ce ce ce
magnifique mandat et aujourd'hui à les
représenter pour moi c'est un honneur
incroyable et indescriptible alors vous
vous vous êtes socialiste j'ai envie de
dire presque socialiste d'ADN socialiste
de naissance
s de gauche plutôt plutôt ou oui je
suissu d'une famille rouge militante
vigneron effectivement é élevé dans dans
ces valeurs là et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il en subsiste dans votre engagement
il en subsiste la la volonté de
d'améliorer le quotidien des gens et en
particulier des des plus vulnérables et
le Sénat me permet
aujourd'hui de défendre des causes
remarquables dont une qui me tient à
cœur c'est la question des violences
sexuelles sur les mineurs j'aijà
récemment eu l'honneur au Sénat de de
faire passer un texte de loi à
l'unanimité sur ces questionsl notamment
dans le sport j'ai l'impression très
sincèrement de à travers cette fonction
là de de pouvoir œuvrer vers plus de
solidarité
vers vers vers un meilleur
accompagnement des plus faibles qui qui
se sentent un peu un peu laésés mais
c'est pas facile aujourd'hui moi j'ai
une pensée vraiment pour eux toute la
journée on va la passer ensemble à aller
visiter ce qui se fait de mieux ici mais
on aura pas beaucoup de temps et donc on
verra pas tout je P qu'on va rencontrer
des personnalités et des personnages
surtout de grands personnages mais bon
surpris allez je vous suis on y va
allons-y cette journée dans l'Aude
ressemble à un véritable festin qui
commence par un cassoulet de Castel
noodari se poursuit avec un plateau de
fromage de chèv chez Jean-Baptiste
gachard et puis évidemment un verre de
vin on ira du côté de Limou de découvrir
le moulin et le pain de Roland Feuillas
pour terminer chez Gill gouon icône de
la gastronomie haoise mais tout de suite
direction le port de Gruissant où nous
attend Jean-Baptiste le pêcheur et ces
merveilles de la mer bonjour alle
bonjour il est content il a d vendre du
poissonour oui donc Jean-Baptiste là on
peut dire que ou c'estite c'est vite
vendu ah bah tant mieux depuis combien
de temps vous êtes pêcheur ici à
grissant moi ça fait 21 ans est-ce que
est que aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment que c'est un métier qui est
considéré le métier commone fait nous
c'est pas péjoratif on appelle ça le
petit métier le le petit métier c'est la
polyvalence oui en fait vous êtes
polypêcheur hein parce qu'il faut savoir
tout pêcher quand on ester pour pouir
s'en sortir il faut savoir tout pêcher
et malheureusement on est sous des
pressions et des contraintes de l'Europe
qui cherche à éteindre complètement
cette polyvalence voilà et cette
polyvalence c'est ce qui nous permet de
vivre si aujourd'hui ben les sols ça
marche pas après-midi je prends ma
barque je vais dans les tank je vais
pêcher des mulets ou des loups et ça on
veut nous l'enlever monsieur le sénateur
la pêche est extrêmement sous le
microscope des autorités européennes qui
disonsle très net emmerde les petits
pêcheurs c'est comme si tout était fait
pour protéger la pêche industrielle et
notamment des pays du Nord et que dès
qu'on est au sud et particulièrement en
Méditerranée on est on est on vous
aiguillonne en permanence ouais ça
démontre que la technostructure est trop
loin des réalités du terrain voilà c'est
ça la principale problématique sont des
gens qui ne connaissent pas les métiers
et les traditions parce queun pêcheur
comme Jean-Baptiste au-delà de son
métier perpétue aussi un savoir-faire
des traditions et ce sont surtout des
des hommes et des femmes qui pratiquent
un écosystème et un territoire donc ils
sont en capacité de le gérer de le
connaître puisque c'est leur fond de
commerce au final et donc la gestion des
espaces lagunaires des étants de la mer
la surpêche c'est pas eux c'est vous la
la courroie de transmission entre ce que
ce que disent les les les artisans
pêcheurs les agriculteurs et les grandes
instiut totalement c'est notre ADN et
c'est surtout notre job au Sénat de
défendre les territoires moi je suis un
fervent défenseur des des traditions et
de nos territoires est-ce qu'on peut
descendre sur le bateau s parce que je
me dis autant qu'à démarrer une une
journée dans l'ude au moins que je sois
monté sur un bateau sans se casser la
gueule c'est mieuxou il faut il faut se
tenir tout le
T toutes ces règles de pêche c'est quand
même un frein énorme à faire votre
métier correctement j'ai envie de dire
parce que vous êtes au milieu des
réglementations on est en plein milieu
je vais vous dire un point où c'est que
ça fait maintenant 4 ans que je paye une
secrétaire ah mais frais bien sûr pour
l'administratif pour l'administratif à
combien de pourcent vous vous sentez
occitan français européens je me semble
premier gruanais ah vous diriez au doit
ouais 2 tiers ocitant gruanais français
ouais et par contre je vous avoue que je
me sens pas trop européen oui je m'en
doute c'est c'est pas possible de de
pouvoir gérer euh au niveau européen des
petites gens comme nous la prudomie par
exemple de gruang a des règles sur la
pêche à l'anguille par exemple qui ne
sont pas les mêmes à la prudomie de Bage
qui est à vol d'oiseau ici à 15 km alors
imaginez-vous la Commission européenne
qui s'amuse à mettre le nez dedans c'est
c'est c'est une patchaque sans fin là
aujourd'hui on est dans dans une Europe
dans laquelle on ne s'y reconnaît plus
moi en tout cas je m'y reconnais plus
parce que malheureusement tous ceux qui
viennent de l'Europe il y a pas une
seule bonne nouvelle voilà chaque fois
qu'il vient quelque chose d'en haut
c'est pour nous tap peu dessus et nous
restra j'insiste et et j'exhorte les les
pêcheurs à s'organiser en syndicat et
c'est le cas a le Comité des pêches
faire poids et pour apporter une une
voix qui qui qui qui permette de faire
évoluer les choses de manière positive
et de de défendre leur spécificité
Jean-Baptiste j'aimerais qu'on élargisse
un petit peu le regard et qu'on parle de
la ressource aliotique en Méditerranée
très longtemps on a dit c'est un vrai
souci il y a plus de poisson où est-ce
qu'on en est aujourd'hui vous savez il y
a mot qui est à la mode c'est
l'effondrement de la biodiversité ça
c'est
extraordinaire moi vous savez j'ai pas
fait d'études je suis allé très peu à
l'école par contre la force que j'ai par
rapport à ces gens justement c'est que
moi à la pêche et à la mer j'y suis tous
les jours il y a quelques années tout le
monde était en crise en disant il y a
plus de merlu il y a plus de merlu il y
a plus de merlu cette année c'est une
très grande année de merlu on vient de
faire une très grande année de sèche
cette année il y a des rougers il y a
des droits dans les étangs je crois qu'à
un moment donné tous ces gens qui
brandissent les tendard de
l'effondrement les tendard de la peur
tout simplement il faudrait qu'il sorte
des bureaux sortir de Facebook et
d'internet et venir un petit peu plus
comme le fait d'ailleurs Sébastien et
comme vous le faites aujourd'hui venez
voir les pêcheurs a quelques années en
arrière on parlait du t il plus de ton
Méditerrané du ton il a jamais eu autant
de ton rouge que ces dernières années
donc la prve on est capable de gérer la
ressource sans problème il y a pas un
effondrement du tout des espèces
Méditerranée en tout cas Méditerranée
dans le golf du Lyon pas le cas il y a
cette impression que les pêcheurs
sont des hommes plus libres peut-être
vous savez quand vous partez à 3h du
matin à la mer il y a juste les feux
allumés voyez que les phes qui
clignotent vous sortez vous êtes seul
mais petit à petit qu le soil monte on
revient on dirait qu'on revient un peu à
la vie ou à la civilisation je dirais
mais cette liberté vous la payez c'est
une liberté qu'on paye au prix de notre
vie mais on dit qu'on a toujours
quelqu'un auudessus de soi un patron
vous votre patron c'est qui le patron
chaque pêcheur beaucoup de pêcheurs sont
pas croyant le patron c'est le temp
c'est lui qui décide merci beaucoup
Jean-Baptiste avec
[Musique]
plaisir bienvenue à la maison Escudier
ou le cassoulet est prêt bon moi
j'attaque par la saucisse de Toulouse
c'est la
fermeté où en est cette guerre de
clocher ancestrale entre les trois
cassoulet celui de Toulouse de Carcasson
et de Castello d'Arry vis que Toulouse
c'est un peu plus tomaté le Castell
d'Arry h avec du saucisson à l'ail
souvent heinouis et Carcasson bon ils
auraient fait ça avec plutôt des
pintades perdre choses comme ça des perd
oui et même de la viande d'agneau à ce
que j'ai entendu dire mais c'est c'est
pas la la recette du vrai cassoulet
voilà ici tu es à la capitale mondiale
du cassoulet c'est la recette donc ça
n'a pas du tout été tranché chaque
encore des Penson Couet non non c'est
c'est trinché par le Parlement voilà
mais attention il faut faire une
distinction entre ce qu'on est en train
de goûter là qui est du cassoulet frais
et la conserve que ce soit en bocau ou
en boîte de tle
ça n'est pas le même produit non moi je
dis souvent c'est quelqu'un qui mange
une viande rouge et quelqu'un qui mange
une viande très cuite on n pas les mêmes
aspects du goût la conerve on dit
souvent que c'est un dépanage ça tu vas
avoir plus de d'envie de le partager
avec des amis le cas soulé faut pas
oublier que c'est d'abord un partage la
problématique de la grippe aviaère dans
un produit où le canard est si important
ça a dû vous vous causer du souci non
faut savoir qu'en 2018 en France on
faisait plus de 30 millions de canards
avec la gripe à on est passé à 18
millions et tous les jours je dis c'est
1500 par de cassoulé qu'il faut
alimenter voilà donc faire et il y a eu
des fois où c'est vraiment passé à cuise
de canard près le prix il a presque
doublé des Canar il a doublé il a doublé
il y a des matières sur le canard qui on
triplé est-ce que ça met en péril le
cassoulet de casseni ça pourrait ça
pourrait parce que aujourd'hui on sait
pas comment s'en relever la filière elle
é aidée quand même par le gouvernement
le législateur
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il fasse de
plus si ce n'est accompagner la filière
pour qu'elle puisse
s'organiser déjà financièrement pour
qu'elle puisse passer le cap et ensuite
la recherche Sébastien est-ce que ce
cassoulet vous y retrouvez le goût du
cassouet de votre enfance tout à fait
surtout comme recherche les co qui
apporte à la fois la texture que M
mettait au fond de la cassole tout à
[Musique]
fait
bon Vincent pour vivre heureux vivant
caché je t'ammène à la ferme de Carus
chez Jean-Baptiste éclair voir des
éleveurs de chèvr et de poules pondeus
tu vas voir c'est le paradis ouais mais
alors il faut grimper comme une
chèvre bonjour
bonjour bienvenue à Carus oh mais
qu'elles sont belles ça crap quand même
beaucoup les Ch ça ça descend ou mais ça
fait 50 ans est là bon ici gachard frère
et sœurs comment se fait la répartition
des tâes votre boulot c'est quoi à vous
Jean-Baptiste alors moi je suis pas trop
les
papiers si je comprends bien CLIRE
s'occupe un peu de de l'administratif
icicoup oui quand on s'est installé il y
avait peut-être une journée par semaine
de papier et là on est à de TR jours he
par semaine tu vois que c'est important
de simplifier les normes les règles pour
faciliter la vie des producteurs et des
agriculteurs don le métier c'est pas de
faire de la paperasse c'est d'élever des
chèvres soit belle en bonne santé
qu'elle donne du fromage extraordinaire
c'est clair combien de chèvres ici il y
a une soantaine d'adultes et une
vingtaine de petites chèvres et poules
on a 650 poules combien 650 poules ah
oui autrement dit vous produisez combien
d' par an on est autour de 200000 à peu
près et le votre débouché principal ce
sont les marchés de la
régionartement on travaille à 90 % en
direct sur les sur les marchés mais
c'est pas courant de faire chèvre et
poule la policulture c'était la manière
dont dont travaillaient nos aïeux nos
grands-parents dans dans chaque village
chacun avait son cochon sa chèvre ses
poules ses canards son petit morceau de
jardin travailler la vigne et on vivait
très bien comme ça et presque en
autarcie hein c'està-dire qu'on se
nourrissait entièrement sur
l'exploitation tout à fait et la cuisine
c'était les loges de la lenteur manger
bon faut prendre le temps de cuisiner
des bons produits et frais ce qui est
compliqué aujourd'hui quand on fait la
policulture c'est que les normes
s'additionnent c'est la solidarité ici
qui s'exprime il y a une entraide qui se
fait entre les éleveurs on est tous
solidaires et on a un peu les mêmes
problèmes donc quand il en a un qui a un
souci il hésite pas à faire appel aux
autres et puis un agriculteur n'a pas le
droit de tomber malade on peut pas le
remplacer du jour au lendemain donc s'il
y a pas cette solidarité entre
agriculteurs entre éleveurs ou entre
viticulteurs quand l'un d'entre eux a un
pépin mais qu qu'est-ce qui se passe à
l'exploitation on a parlé de vos
fromages on n rien goûté
on on va y passer allez venez venez
venez ça donne TR
envie voilà les chèvres la production de
la ferme
Carus celui-là j'aime bien en chèvre
chaud et là les saveurs s'affinent et
puis là voilà là jusqu'au plus sec quoi
faut se faire plaisir voilà moi je mais
faut partager
aussi il a ce gras quand même cette
richesse crémeux c'est bon très très bon
je pense qu'on pourrait bien la ier avec
un petit peu de verre rouge je crois
qu'il y a ce qu'il faut dans ce
département allez on y va on va à Limou
à Limou mais oui bien sûr merci à vous
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Claire qu'est-ce que c'est ce beau
château Sébastien al ça c'est le château
de flandri qui appartient à la cave du
surur d'Arc ah le surur d'Arc c'est la
c'est la coopérative de Limou c'est là
qu'on fait le principal de la blanquette
de Limou voilà de l'ensemble du
territoire de liimou d'ailleurs le
président de la cave est là dans dans
les vignes voir bonjour Qu'est-ce que
vous êtes en train de faire pierlouis et
ben là je est je suis en train
défeuiller parce que c'est vrai que
cette année vous voyez il y a des tâches
de Milu hein le MU c'est une moisissure
qui s'attaque aux feuilles et qui va
empêcher l'assimulation chlorophilienne
en quelque sorte c'est ça mais aussi ce
qu'on a la spécificité que l'on a cette
année c'est que au-delà de de l'attaque
sur feuille on est des attaques
directement sur grappe de mémoire
d'ancien il y a très longtemps qu
n'avait pas vu des attaques de de Milu
de cette ampleur nous sommes dans un
schéma de de raisonnement viign et aussi
on utilise beaucoup plus de produits je
dirais
euh des biocontrôles qu'on appelle
c'est-à-dire qui ont moins d'impact sur
l'environnement dans l'Aude il y a
pratiquement un vigneron dans chaque
famille aujourd'hui encore c'est le
premier secteur économique du
département de l'ode la viticulture on
est dans une région relativement
viticole l'angodoc maintenant
l'Occitanie qui doit produire à peu près
30 % de la production de vin française
euh 14 ou 15 millions d' heectolitres
par an et le département de l'ode tient
toute sa part dans dans cette production
à l'intérieur de
l'appellation Limou la la cave
coopérative en production représente
combien on représente à peu près 65 à 6
10 % des volumes produits sur l'air
d'appellation l'économie de ce
territoire là de Limou est assis sur la
coopérative c'est la première entreprise
du territoire qui permet de mutualiser
les moyens qui permet de mettre des
moyens en place pour pouvoir conquérir
des marchés et permettre à ces gens-là
de vivre correctement dans leur pays
vous avez créé un événement ici toqu et
clocher d'où ces bornes qui sont
plantées en bout de de rang avec les
noms des grands chefs les grands chefs
qui nous ont accompagné qui nous ont
parrainé depuis le début et c'est une
fierté pour nous associer le nom de ces
grands chefs à nos produits mais vous
Sébastien vous êtes vigneron vous aussi
oui indépendant indépendant et en bio au
final la conduite bio coûte
excessivement cher parce qu'il faut
travailler le sol passer très souvent
travailler à la main en recuter beaucoup
de monde et que si derrière vous pouvez
pas valoriser avec des produits de
qualité et des bouteilles avec des bons
prix vous pouvez pas vous en sortir vous
ça vous tente par exemple vous avez été
tenté de faire vos productions en bio
alors non je le dis clairement parce que
on est dans un climat un peu particulier
à Limou où on peut on le voit cette
année les difficultés que l'on a avec
une pression une maladie importante où
la pérenité de nos exploitations peut
être engagé je dirais Sébastien ça
demanderait presque une harmonisation
parce que la finalité de tout ça c'est
le consommateur sur l'étiquette ouais et
en plus d'ici la fin de l'année avec les
normes européennes au niveau de
l'étiquetage il va falloir rajouter la
composition les ingrédients que vous
trouvez dans le dans le vin comme une
recette de cuisine cuisine tout à fait
donc on va pas dans la simplification
des choses bien au contraire on va pas
tellement dans le bon sens là il est
vrai que on rentre dans des schémas
vraiment très complexes et qui vont être
aussi très très difficilement
compréhensible par les consommateurs
comment le vigneron réussir à gagner sa
vie correctement va pouvoir continuer à
travailler et l'agriculteur en général
par rapport à toutes les normes qui lui
sont imposées Sébastien pierrelouis 1000
questions restent encore en suspens mais
moi je dis la réponse elle est au fond
de la
[Musique]
bouteille
pensez que nous
attend rol
oui bonjour rol il
attendait merci de nous recevoir au
moulin salut séastien bonsoir ce qui est
extrêmement important avec un moulin à
c'est que on n'est pas vraiment le
maître du jeu c'est le moulin qui est
notre maître pas histoire aussi pour le
pain le boulanger n'est pas vraiment le
maître de son pain il est dominé quand
même par son pain dominé c'est pas
forcément le le bon terme mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il faut se mettre au
service d'eux faire preuve de la plus
grande abnégation si on est enfermé dans
les filtres terribles de l'ego à vouloir
dominer la matière c'est-à-dire que si
on veut absolument être dominant du pain
on fait pas du pain on fait un machin un
truc un bitule on fait un outil pour
saucer pour manger des sandwiches et
cetera mais le pain c'est autre chose
que ça quoi voilà et est-ce que c'est
pas le génie du du pain justement de se
laisser un peu emmener euh par son par
la matière justement surtout si on fait
ce que on essaie de faire ici depuis 20
ans ce qu'on appelle de la variabilité
génétique donc autrement dit quand en
plus c'est blé anciens on les fait
pousser dans des sols vivants c'est le
sol qui lui-même est nourricier on ne
met aucun intran et c'est la fertilité
du sol qui va nourrir ces blés qui ont
des génétiques différentes donc
autrement en dit on est dans un autre
monde que quand un ministre vient parler
à l'Assemblée nationale de la chute de
la biodiversité en disant on vient de
perdre le dernier Mâ rhinocérose blanc
on voit la tête des députés on n'a pas
le sentiment que ça all travaille
beaucoup au tripe voyez alors que quand
on fait manger de la biodiversité je
pense que c'est le meilleur moment je
pense même qu'elle peut parler au-delà
du cerveau au-delà du cortex au-delà du
système cognitif elle va parler aux
cellules en si je suis venu dans
l'alimentation c'est parce que je pense
P que le le socle le pour construire
quelque chose qui peut participer à à
donner les moyens à nos contemporaines
de se
conscientiser d'ouvrir leur esprit
d'ouvrir leur cœur d'ouvrir leur liaison
je pense que le moyen le plus efficace
efficient simple facile accessible à
tous c'est l'alimentation et et donc
voilà c'est le socle de l'alimentation
ça demeure quand même le pain quoi vous
savez nous on a environ suivant comment
on regarde les données scientifiques
entre 31000 les 40000 gênnes un gène
c'est une carte programme entre
guillemets le Grand épotre Ancien en a
145000 donc ce qui veut dire que sur le
plan de Liné il est plus intelligent que
nous qu'est-ce que vous pensez de du
gluten bashing je pense que c'est
difficile de mettre en juste position un
aliment don grosso modo justement on
nous dit depuis 2000 ans qui représente
le sacré le divin et cetera et d'en
transformer d'en faire le diable je
pense que c'est nous qui avons souci
c'est pas le gluten en tant que telo
c'est pas le pain qui a un souci surtout
que ce que l'on raconte sur le gluten
c'est un tissu de bêtises de de mensonge
et honté voilà donc il faut réapprendre
aux gens ouis à manger Roland vous avez
quand même quelques quelques petits
pains pour nous pour nous montrer votre
travail voilà trois exemplaires qui sont
intéressants parce que on a trois étage
de la généalogie du
blé don la couleur de l'amie est
parfaitement naturelle
vous savez quoi le Roland votre pain il
a le goût du
[Musique]
grain bon Sébastien vous m'avez présenté
des gens formidable alors c'est mon tour
de vous emmener chez un très grand chef
Gilles Goujon
méonne pas trop de teetrouver dans ton
jardin parce que il faut bien dire quand
on est un grand chef il faut des grands
produits
[Musique]
d'ailleur c'est la meilleure courgette
la ch deette courette la meilleure
courette du mondez direction la
cuisine mign LEF
atitleurur sénateur qui
va il nous faut juste un petit peu pour
voir
refermer d'accord
allez on commence par le fond et on
tourne voilà encore encore encore c'est
parfait alors on referme et après on
tourne alors pendant qu'on fait la
petite chose blanquette et que la selle
cuit on va mettre ça au fond vapeur 5
minutes on est prêt on a passé une
journée incroyable on a le sentiment que
cette croisade albigeoise a été en fait
l'annexion de l'Occitanie au ro de
France ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'Occitanie le territoire ocitain et le
territoire qui a vu nîre les trouadours
l'amour pour toi l'accueil
l'hospé la poésie tout à fait donc ça on
est fier de cette histoire ce
département de l'ude a énormément d'atou
parce qu'on a un territoire béni des
dieux de la mer à la montagne vous
l'avez vu la Carcassonne c'est c'est un
pays où on trouve t un concentré de
France ce département et le Sénat et
justement c'est c'est un lieu qui
représente l'ensemble de cette unersité
française de de tous ces départements et
je crois que cette cette chambre hte
représente bien ce qu'est la France
notre tradition notre histoire qu'est-ce
qui permet d'agréger les ocitants qui
ont un caractère particulier à cette
nation française profondément attaché à
la République en ocitanie nous sommes
pas des séparatistes mais que la
République tienne compte de nos
spécificités de nos traditions de nos
savoir-faire et la richesse de la France
c'est ça on sent bien que votre
territoire il vous anime en quelque
sorte il vous il vous nourrit c'est
quelle chance que l'on a de vivre dans
un pays aussi aussi extraordinaire et
formidable soyons en fiier et que le
pouvoir central donne la parole et mett
en avant justement ces spécificités là
de de l'ensemble de nos territoires à la
fois métropole et nos territoires ultra
Maré et voilà monessieurs est oh quel
merveille qu'est-ce que c'est ah c'est
notre selle de chevau avec un peu de
tomate avec un petit beur d'herbe à
l'intérieur la fameuse courgette fleu du
sénateur oh une belle blanquette de riz
de veau champignon oh là là un tout
petit petit morceau de S et là justement
le fameux jus de chevreau à la népite
dans le jus de
chevux merci Monsieur sénateur de tant
de bonheur un bonheur que vous partagez
j'espère avec nous alors le plat ça sera
difficile mais évidemment l'émission
elle vous est entièrement offerte et
vous la retrouverez d'ailleurs sur la
plateforme
publsena.fr à très vite là maintenant je
pe plus rien pour
[Musique]
vous c'était manger S vautter avec
Mutualia la mutuelle des
[Musique]
territoires